I was in a kind of a sad mood in LA but
fine it was wrong nothing why you saying
it's it's honestly stupid and what is it
please
it'll piss you off no along I promise
not to be pissed off you know I was a
little bummed because I thought it was a
missed opportunity just the fact that I
had come up with this like commercial
idea for us to do in LA with a bunch of
celebrities and things like that and I
was kind of sad that like the
opportunity went away and whoever did
anything else I i when i read your idea
yeah I said this is a guy who so
desperately wants to get on the air that
he's coming up with dumb [ __ ] now
literally like I spent weeks on it and
just moved on that put yourself putting
it too but remember I promised five
minutes ago I wouldn't be pissed off at
you now my shoes as a creative person
from five cent were you bummed out
because I didn't think it was a great
idea what and you're walking around
moping and bumming everybody I mean you
complain about your bad mood sometimes
yeah but I'm the star of the [ __ ]
show if I'm making material you gotta
[ __ ] be perky and peppy imagine like
I spent weeks with this concept I put it
together like three seconds to reject it
that's what I'm saying so after all that
work literally only the only feedback I
got was a giant X through the thing yeah
I use a strikethrough on the on
wordperfect tell everyone your idea go
ahead and start my commercial oh okay
this is a pitch okay so picture if
you're at home it starts off it's a
pleasant day in sunny Los Angeles or
whatever we're seeing the new Sirius
building it's gorgeous its
state-of-the-art like it's a place any
celebrity would want to be at we go into
the lobby next slide so inside there are
all these a list celebrities everywhere
everyone is dying to be on your show
there's so many people dying to be on
your show like people are getting turned
away right like Oprah's outside peeking
and she's mad everyone wants to be on
your show every celebrity is dying to
get there Stern interview anyways
there's this agent he's at the lobby and
he's looking for his client he can't
find her anywhere and that's when we see
a sign behind the desk that says
basement keep out next slide
alright now here's where the commercial
gets interesting right we're not in the
serious Los Angeles Lobby anymore we're
in the serious basement and for some
reason there's like a deep well in the
hole and in the hole there's like a
woman moaning inside the well right but
who is this woman next slide we see it's
Ellen DeGeneres she's being held like
deep in a well like Silence of the Lambs
style right Robins staring at me we draw
a head come on okay so anyways she's in
the well and some guys like looking over
and telling of her lotion on skin but
like you know who is this person next
slide we see it's Howard Stern is
holding your hostage you're like Buffalo
Bill or whatever we're like why is
Howard you know holding celebrities
hostage why is he keeping Ellen in a
well next slide we go back to Howard's
dressing room I don't know people on the
radio can understand this or whatever
oh they understand you just fine so we
find out what Howard is actually doing
is he's making skin suits of celebrity
bodies there's a body suit and there's a
tattoo that says I love Molly on it
which can only mean one thing
next slide Howard's dancing around in a
Jimmy Kimmel bodysuit you've skinned him
alive Jimmy's head is sitting on ladders
Jimmy have breasts please running around
in celebrity skin like in silence a
little and right and then we zoom in on
Jimmy Kimmel's head and Jimmy Kimmel
says the tagline which is nobody gets
inside celebrities like Howard Stern
I'm cleaning like you get inside got it
we got got it I get inside their minds
and their bodies okay great idea
okay I could make a joke and say could
you guys please send in the guys in the
white suits come after Matt might be the
Joker right our job we're only seeing
the very early days yes you're on your
way to be blown out superhero going oh I
didn't feel that this a was worth
hassling celebrities to sit and film
Ellen DeGeneres trapped in a well while
I'm making a skin
yeah I'm dancing around Jimmy's body and
chopping off his head is making Robin
land
robbers laughing but not over the idea
Robins laughing in the well made her
laugh calling up Ellen DeGeneres and
asking her to jump into a well and while
I make a skin suit skin she's laughing
because you're being absurd now when I
saw this idea it's comedy
this is what went through my mind yes I
say ma'am ed has had success on the show
before with me getting upset about his
pitches and it was funny
now he's pitching something so [ __ ]
ridiculous no one will even believe that
he believes in it I was wrong like that
I was wrong like that you really do
believe in this constant I believe in
everything I hand to you I believe it
they tell me you're a very good writer
and I agree
I know it's something things you've done
[Music]